ces fonds que la famille basée à moyens
on fait un petit retour ensemble
je suis là bas de celle-ci a été pris
pour un daft punk de la fin il faut que
tu te met au vert je vais peut-être une
idée
ces villages qui m'envoient je suis
chauffeur
tu le connais comme c'est mon producteur
même says c'est au nom soit excepté juge
la souffrance invasion gicollet les
pendules et j'y tiens j'en connais
certains et vernet vernet du xviiie
parce que moi tous les vandales du
xviiie je les connais m'ad'ailleurs 18e
et 20e et je les connais tous et mes
potes et en plus ils ont fumé tous les
arrondissements de paris
un par un ils ont tout fait aux français
c'est comme tous les pauvres ouvrir tous
les points que vous insulter à longueur
de journée et vous savez pourquoi vous
les détestez autant par ce qui vous
ressemble
une petite copine
je vous apprends moi serment j'ai
beaucoup trop vocabulaire pour ça ça
parce que vous êtes jeune je suis sûr
vous aurez maîtres bloc et vous seriez
mais faire du rap rock du rap
révolutionnaire je veux toujours après
volution je te donnais plus lourd
ça fait dans ma cité du poro coûté la
musique même un marteau piqueur pour les
oreilles pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
pas tous car c'est une promesse que j'ai
faite à ma femme je ne tiens mes
promesses
ouf c'est la première fois qu'ils en
demandent trop ma défense
moi c'est pour diriger d'un arabe